your new record uh the female Gucci Mane
is fire thanks appreciate it what makes
you the female Gucci Mane this is what
they be seeing I don't know ask the
people let's ask the people because I
don't know that's what they say for I
ain't just calling myself that they be
saying that they said it so much I I
just made a song about it I'm not
calling myself the female Gucci but if
that's what y'all want to say
because it just went like I heard the
beat and I'm like okay female Gucci man
I just kept rapping have has do you know
if Gucci's heard this record I don't
know did you like send it off to him
like Hey man I did [__] out no I'm sure
my fans didn't tags him or something
with him he probably didn't hurt it yeah
yeah uh are you the type of person if
you're on the road because you've been
getting bags running around performing
everywhere do you hit the local strip
club to support the local talent no I'm
not gonna lie I don't like strip clubs
really I don't what's wrong with that I
don't like clubs period I ain't even
gonna say I don't like strip clubs I
don't like clothes she's like unless
they're paying me yes unless they plan
me but even when they do pack me I'm
gonna be honest I don't like the club if
it's fun and y'all turn me up then it's
different but honestly I don't like the
club I don't like when strippers be
trying to dance on me and do all that
unless I ask you don't just come over to
me
yeah see the money yeah come down come
sit on me I don't want none of that so
I'm letting y'all know now you would
like to keep your money no not even that
just don't even come like if I approach
you and I'll tell you like yeah that's
different but for you to just if you're
showing love that's cool hey Bobby but I
don't be I don't know I don't be with
all that cause I'm I don't like strip
clubs I don't like clubs period I'm not
I'm not friendly but I [__] with whoever
[__] with me you know so you rather
you're like would you consider yourself
a homebody yeah I am you'll be at the
crib yeah I do chilling yeah I do I'll
be chilling I used to be outside should
I still get outside but that's when I
want to right it ain't just like because
I do it I get paid to do it all the time
I saw you in uh you were in Miami was it
for spring break that looked pretty wild
yeah that was fun how was that look you
got you guys look like it was like
vintage spring break action-popping
that's why they were saying freed me it
was fun it's [__] yeah it was fun I had
them hoes turn we was outside
I mean you were literally outside yeah I
want to say you were running around with
no shirt on am I tripping no I had a
bikini top on okay maybe I'm tripping
then I think I feel like I saw one of
your Vlogs and I was like is she got no
shirt all day no well shout out to you I
would but no that wouldn't mean uh are
you working on an album right now uh I'm
working I got a lot of music I'll just
be working on songs but it's so many
good ones we trying to see which ones to
put on a little mixtape or whatever I'll
drop like a mixtape because you've been
putting singles out yeah I don't want to
drop no album
I know they want me to drop it off but I
just want to start small and see what
they do and then go crazy
did you have any idea when you wrapped
the coochie pink the booty hole Brown
that uh that would be such a viral no
because I hear that [__] all the [__]
time
it's crazy my booty hole Brown it's such
a it's like you crack me up now because
it's just like y'all really fine I laugh
like y'all really find this funny and it
just makes me sure it didn't make me
laugh at first because I'm like I'm
being dead serious yeah uh like I have
my boy a propane send me your [__] maybe
like two months ago and he was like uh
yo this shit's about to be huge really
everybody was saying that and then I
heard the the song and I was like this
is different this [__] is raw how was
different it was just very it's a very
transparent song thank you it's a very
transparent oh we missed our clap we
gotta get it right there it is wow boom
yeah and then like uh you the the line
about trying to find your kid a new
Pappy just had me die that was money
people everybody was laughing but I did
think I was just ripping I didn't know
it was funny like I'll be just being
real hilarious yeah I'm just talking and
then they'd be laughing I'd be like what
I say what did I say who's been like one
of the celebrities that you saw like
singing along your [__] or posting your
[__] that you were like whoa that's
crazy like my song's that big like that
it reached this person I ain't gonna lie
I probably don't even remember now
because it's just it's so many so many
of them now you you see it I'd be
surprised about all of them for real
cause I ain't know the song was gonna
even I'm like yeah I really like this
song
correct me from the cardi B say
something about it yeah everybody when I
say everybody everybody know mama that's
why I'm shocked so every time it's a new
person I'll just be like hey it's crazy
it's just going all around I feel like a
pound town remix with cardi B would be
Monumental they were saying that it's a
lot of people that was like it's a lot
of people I want to put on there I don't
know how long who do you want to put on
it I don't know I don't want to name
drop nobody well you know Anna Lee
Chopper did two like officially two
remixes of slept me out I know I do like
three or four I might do something like
that
or just put her body on the same song
you could and just have it you know
Trina with Trina would be dope a lot of
people it's a lot of people I could
think of